[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi ricordate la prima volta in cui vi
siete fermati ad osservare il cielo
stellato
scommetto che questa osservazione avrà
suscitato in voi diverse reazioni
c'è chi si è sentito perso ma
incuriosito e affascinato
oppure chi immerso nei suoi pensieri è
stato sovrastato dalla malinconia e si è
sentito piccolo piccolo nessuno però può
essere ma rimasto indifferente
fin dall'antichità gli uomini si sono
fermati ad ammirare la volta celeste e
come noi ne sono rimasti affascinati
hanno espresso questo fascino attraverso
la scrittura la poesia la musica e hanno
tentato in tutti i modi di capire che
cosa fossero le stelle le popolazioni
antiche avevano diversi modi di veder le
stelle
secondo la cosmologica ebraica per
esempio su ogni stella vedrebbe un
angelo e le costellazioni sarebbero
gruppi di spiriti celesti legati tra
loro da uno stretto rapporto di
collaborazione gli aztechi pensavano che
le stelle fossero le protettrici dei
guerrieri caduti in battaglia
un'altra visione viene presentata dagli
indios dell'impero inca loro pensavano
che le stelle fossero le dame di corte
della luna e per questo motivo era loro
riservato uno spazio attorno alla loro
sovrana
il più vicino possibile per servirla al
meglio credevano infatti che le stelle
si spostassero seguendo non il sole ma
la luna perché si vedevano solo di notte
ad oggi siamo giunti alla conclusione
che le stelle sono dei corpi celesti in
grado di brillare di luce propria ma
possiamo sostenere che esse non
rappresentano più un mistero per noi
possiamo affermare che siano solo questo
così per la prima volta ho riflettuto
sulle stelle
ho cercato i significati gli
insegnamenti celati dietro ad esse direi
dunque di iniziare questo viaggio alla
scoperta delle stelle
cominciamo con una domanda l'apparenza
inganna
quante volte nella nostra vita ci capita
di rimanere sorpresi nel capire che
qualcosa diverso da come sembra
succede con le persone gli oggetti i
film i libri con le più semplici scene
di vita quotidiana
ebbene accade anche con le stelle dalla
terra ci appaiono così vicine tra loro
tanto da riuscire a raggrupparle in
costellazioni elementi rivelatesi
fondamentali per orientamento dell'uomo
tuttavia ogni stella vista dall'altra
centinaia migliaia di anni luce è tutta
un'illusione illusione che ha avuto e
continuo ad avere il potere di fluence
arci tramite l'astrologia un'altra
stranezza riguarda le loro dimensioni
dalla terra infatti può sembrare che una
stella sia più grandi di un'altra quando
nella realtà la situazione si inverte da
tutte queste considerazioni si può
rispondere alla nostra domanda
ebbene sì l'apparenza inganna e le
stelle ne sono il vero e proprio emblema
ma cos'altro si può imparare dalle
stelle
secondo la poetessa alda merini
anche se la finestra stessa non tutti
vedono le stesse cose
la veduta dipende dallo sguardo
una delle cose più importanti che ci
siano i nas pola è quella di imparare ad
essere flessibili sui propri punti di
vista ci assegnano lavori il gruppo
ricerche
per studiare un fenomeno da diverse
prospettive con le stelle
questo è più complicato siamo abituati a
vedere tutto ciò che ci circonda da una
sola prospettiva quella terrestre senza
rendersi conto che ne esistono molte
altre
immaginiamo di trovarci su marte e
osservare la volta celeste ci renderemo
subito conto che alcune stelle non
occupano la medesima posizione osservato
dalla terra noi vediamo le stelle
cambiare loco ma loro ruotando su se
stesse mantengono la loro collocazione
direi che è proprio il caso di affermare
che è solo una questione di punti di
vista
salvador dalì sosteneva che quando una
persona osserva il cielo stellato è come
se volesse cercare la propria dimensione
dispersa nell'universo strano penserete
come possiamo credere di rivedere noi
stessi in quelle masse infuocate beh io
credo che le stelle siano lo specchio
dell'anima
grazie ad esse riusciamo a rivedere i
nostri lati più interiori le paure più
profonde e gli affetti più importanti
davanti alle stelle
nessuno ha scampo ricco o povero giovane
o anziano ognuno è tenuto a fare i conti
con se stesso il che può essere
spaventoso perché ci si sente nudi
spogliati da tutte le sicurezze e privi
della propria corazza credo però ne
valga la pena
perché solo così affrontando le proprie
paure le proprie debolezze ci si sente i
vivi e si ha la possibilità di scoprire
la t di se stessi che di cui non si era
a conoscenza oppure che si credevano
perduti
insomma davanti alle stelle torniamo un
po bambini più attenti più spensierati
con il cuore traboccante d'amore e gli
occhi colmi di curiosità stephen hawking
illustro astrofisico che da poco ci ha
lasciato diceva guardate le stelle e non
i vostri piedi
siate curiosi e dunque stasera uscite di
casa
trovate un punto buio nel cielo
sollevate il naso all'insù e osservate
la volta celeste come se fosse la prima
volta
scoprirete tanto di voi stessi
imparerete a sognare grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
così